across britain as indeed across many
parts of the world people are trying to
work out how to keep their heads above
financial water in the coming months
getting to the stage now where
do i pay for food or do i pay for heat
we saw watch our smart meter thinking
is it going to be a really painful month
this month i'm going to be afraid to
switch the lights on
because the power bill is going to be
ridiculous
but how much of an impact will higher
energy bills have to find out we need to
drill down into what we spend our money
on and this bar here shows the weekly
spending of an average household i know
there's no such thing but on balance 58
588 pounds a week that's the average
spending and let's just break it down
you can see about 53 pounds goes on
restaurants and hotels a week on average
you've got spending on recreation and
culture that's 75 pounds a week 82
pounds on transport uh 64 pounds on food
and drink you can see how it adds up and
then you've got other things that you
can't avoid things like mortgage and
council tax 50 pounds on that and by far
away the biggest 146 pounds on income
tax but then on top of all of that
there it is electricity and gas 25
pounds now it may not sound like much
but bear in mind that's based on bills
back in 2020 and if the energy price cap
goes up to 2 000 pounds this spring as
the formula suggests we'll look at the
red slice it goes up to 38 pounds a week
and if the price cap rises again later
on this year to 2400 pounds as again
looks plausible based on the wholesale
prices
it's up to 46 pounds a week now to put
that into context let's look at spending
on heats in power so it's basically that
red slice is a proportion of the total
going back to 1917. you can see it was
high in the 70s and the 80s and then it
came down in the 90s the late 90s and
the 2000s but if you have that 2000
pound price cap look at what happens to
that red line up to 5.6 percent of
spending that's the highest since the
late eighties and a two thousand four
hundred pound price cap would take them
up to six point eight percent of
spending that would be the highest on
record even higher than we saw in the
energy crisis that famous energy crisis
of the 1970s and bear in mind the impact
is greater for different households so
what we're going to do is go back to
those bars showing spending you can see
there's the average there we're also
going to look at the top 10 percent and
the lowest 10 in terms of their spending
and you can see there are energy bills
there after those two expected price cap
increases and for the average uh it is
around seven percent so there's seven
percent of spending but just look for
the top 10 you're talking about four
percent of spending so much smaller in
proportionate terms and for the lowest
tenth you're talking about 13
of spending that is a massive
squeeze now it's worth saying the energy
bill could be even worse than the 1970s
but there is a question as to whether we
can expect a repeat of the energy crisis
in other respects so are we going to see
three day weeks mass shutdowns are we
going to see power cuts the business
secretary says no
there is absolutely no question mr
speaker of the lights going out or
people being unable to heat their homes
there will be no
three-day working weeks or a throwback
to the 1970s
so there we are that's pretty clear but
part of the reason he is probably
actually right comes down to this these
bars show you what share of people
worked in different sectors and years
gone by so going all the way back to
1841. look in particular at the black
bar that's manufacturing and you can see
that while in the 1960s and into the 70s
you've got about 40 percent of people so
an enormous section of the workforce who
did work in manufacturing and energy so
directly affected by any shutdowns roll
on because these are high energy sectors
we're all on to the 2000s and you're
talking about 10 of people working in
manufacturing and energy simply put
there is less industrial base to shut
down if there are shutdowns they'll
probably mostly be in china and as far
as we can tell that is already happening
and that implies more supply chain
problems for a lot longer and it's not
just product manufacturing energy is the
backbone of pretty much every product
especially things like fertilizers
we paid six dollars per per unit of gas
uh
last year at this time and uh and today
we're at uh close to 40. so so we have
it's a significant volatility so
so more more than we've ever seen
so they and others have been cutting
back production and prices higher
fertilizer prices means higher prices
for farmers which means well back to
this chart while the initial impact of
energy prices might be over there
in the coming months by the end of the
year we'll also see the impact in terms
of higher food prices as well you see
where this is heading an energy crisis
is really an everything crisis the
longer prices are high the more they
push up the price of everything it looks
increasingly like a perfect storm so on
top of higher energy bills over there
that's energy that's going up you've
also got national insurance the health
and social care level remember that's
coming in this april and you've got more
people as well being pulled into higher
income tax bands and you've got the
impact of higher interest rates from the
bank of england they're going up as well
so all told you're talking about look at
the red bit over a third of the typical
spending going up this spring and that's
before you've got the inflationary
impact elsewhere for many families this
may amount to an almost unprecedented
price shock
there are about two million households
in england that are in fuel stress who
pay more than 10 of their
household incomes on energy bills which
is a general sign of energy being
unaffordable and what we found was that
as soon as when prices jump by more than
50 overnight this number will triple to
more than 6 million
when you put it all together we are
talking about the kind of hit to real
incomes you don't tend to see outside of
a serious recession which is why this is
likely to be one of the defining issues
of the year